el pueblo japonés tuvo este viernes
donde yo viví sin duda de renuncia por
segunda vez a su cargo de primer
ministro a sus 65 años al mandatario
nipón explicó que estaba sufriendo un
retorno de su antigua enfermedad crónica
que ya le había obligado a renunciar en
2007 un año después de haber sido
elegido por primera vez
pero acá dadas mis enfermedades y mis
tratamientos a abandonar haití fueron
acá y mi imperfecto estado de salud se
han dado de malo coto no puedo permitir
que estas condiciones comprometan mis
decisiones políticas o mis resultados
otra ahora que no puedo cumplir con el
mandato y la confianza de la gente joven
hasta cádiz
he decidido dejar el cargo de primer
ministro a la luz de tarde de vuelta en
el cargo desde hace casi ocho años ave
apareció visiblemente conmovido el
ministro también dijo que estaba
profundamente apenado con el pueblo
japonés por haber dejado su puesto un
año antes de lo previsto y en medio de
la crisis de coronavirus foto que crece
estoy sorprendido parecía muy cansado
pero no pensé que renunciaría desearía
que pudiera trabajar más duro y quedarse
como primer ministro un poco más
el mandatario se negó este viernes a
expresar públicamente su preferencia por
un sucesor diciendo que todas las
personas cuyos nombres circulan son
personas muy capaces hasta que se
designe el próximo primer ministro
japonés a ver aseguró que se mantendrá
firme en el cargo